wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
zuerst wird eine idee für ein artikel
vorgeschlagen und dann mit der
redaktionsleitung gesprochen habe der
letzte schnaps gestern gut verkraftet
erst dann beginnen die reporter zu
recherchieren und interviews zu machen
dann werden die artikel geschrieben
danach wird lektoriert zum schluss
werden dann alle artikel zusammengefasst
von den grafikern und dann erst geht das
ganze in den druck war das klingt nach
viel arbeit
natürlich wir sind alle profis und wir
wollen es auch gar nicht anders
das hier ist die lokalredaktion das herz
der zeitung
ich möchte mich noch einmal sehr
bedanken dass die anzeige kostenlos
abgedruckt wird
kein problem dafür ist mein chef nicht
wahr
da kann man hin und wieder auch mal
jemanden einen gefallen tun
ich weiß dass wirklich sehr zu schätzen
wir können ja mal einen kaffee trinken
gehen wenn sie wollen
ich zahl auch also klar ich meine das
ist ja etwas gutes ich war
[Musik]